ça voulait ouais vous êtes contre lui
vous êtes contre le port de la fourrure
ça me paraît évident bah non ça serait
dirigée par un quasi monopole est
tellement pour les hommes je n'aime pas
tellement mais pour les femmes tout ça
c'est joli mais là vous parlez de
l'esthétisme willémoise oubliée qui
l'intéressé c'est séverine hypocrisie
totale alors de quoi à part ça vous
dérangerait l'elysée chaussures non mais
attendez moi j'ai rien j'ai regardé les
vias et des fois ça du lac a fait du
fait d'accord mais tu la quittes boutons
de nacre été arraché à à une huître
c'est très cruel aussi mais un film de
truffaut je crois avec françoise dorléac
et gens d'essayer
ils sont d'abord liés aux abus d'orly et
il est plus douce et à un moment donné
françoise dorléac je trouvais génial
dix agents design tu vois il ya une
femme qui porte une robe panthère
imprimé panthère et ça c'est les femmes
qui aiment l'amour ah oui c'est dans
peau douce c'est un signe alors karl
lagerfeld vous dessinez un maintenant je
vais acheter un manteau de fourrure
ça sert à rien il va karl lagerfeld la
dent dure à parce que vous vous avez dit
pas inquiet mais défendent alors je
parle jeudi passé à dent dure mais ce
que ce sont les vautours caresser karl
lagarfeld non mais vous vous êtes un peu
comme pierre cardin sur vous dessinez
plein de choses plein d'objets plein de
trucs et contrat de licence que lui dont
vous semble de garde à vous dites c'est
devenu un marchand de soupe
il ya maxime brand pas un oui d'accord
donc oui d'accord oui enfin il y aura
pas lui aura pas à manger chez lagerfeld
galerie jamais non non non non vous dit
en parlant de chanel with each and elle
n'aurait pas aimé je n'aurais pas
apprécié je pense que je peux vous dire
il l'a elle l'aurait d'été à dalian on
est alors en parlant de chloé qui est
une maison pour laquelle vous avez
longtemps dessiné chloé vient d'engager
la fille du beatles paul mccartney qui
s'appelle stella mccartney et vous avez
déclaré moi je voyais je trouve ça drôle
pour poser quand même pas très gentil
visite il voulait un nom ils l'ont eue
mais dans la musique à l'abri que je
raconte l'histoire de cette faute
oui je sollicite les noms et 2010 qui a
écrit ça et aussi besoin de téléphone de
neige
il n'a pas pu me joindre il a écrit ça
il me dit tu comprends c'est comme ça
que tu parles hdmi oui bah oui d'accord
que tu l'aies dire je n'ai pas dit mais
tu parles comme ça
quant à la mauvaise réputation c'est
vraiment toi je les lui j'ai cru que
vous l'aviez dit est ce que ça aurait
été prêt à le dire bon vous avez on peut
pas dire que son père est tellement
inconnue et les qu'il est quand même un
peu plus connue qu'est le dong hwa
succès du marché retient depuis
oui alors quand c'est lui le film de
robert altman ça peut prêt-à-porter
vous étiez il y avait quelqu'un qui
parlait de vous on comprenait que
c'était vous étiez pas cité et on disait
que j'étais un voleur mais sont-ce
copieurs pas au sens de deux volets et
vous avez essayé de faire interdire le
film en france on n'a qu'un organisme du
coupé la séquence et dans certains pays
je suis arrivé en allemagne j'étais
arrivé à faire mettre un bip sur le mode
voleur mais oui mais ça a retardé la
sortie après les films tu es passé
d'alcoolique et oui et on rien qu'en
france c'est sorti comme ça quand même
non bonjour avait patiemment 6,6 en
allemagne est arrivé il ya des pics est
terrible elle fait interdire
complètement le film c'est à dire il a
été très très retardé le temps que le
jugement soit
accepter appel et compagnie si si il y
avait aucune raison mais c'est surtout
parce que c'était un mauvais film ça
aurait été un très bon film et blattmann
a fait près des très très beau film mais
il l'a été pas bon donc c'était bien
scrupule à le faire interdire la prise
de kaiser de la mode
il a écrit sur la cub faut que tu enlève
ton caleçon est un chanteur qui sont il
y très sympathique les seules personnes
qui trouve grâce à vos yeux karl
lagerfeld c'est le seul gotha quoi vous
raffolez des particules et des têtes
couronnées dans tous nos il ya plein
d'autres gens aussi j'espère en tout cas
je peux vous avez déclaré par exemple
que vous êtes prisonniers que monaco je
veux pas les deux contraire l'isaf et
j'habite amman ap personne n'est parfait
dit marie laforêt j'étais très ami avec
les monaco vous avez déclaré sur canal
jean louis vous avez déclaré le prince
albert est très spirituel et oui ça peut
tout à fait ça vous confirmez
c'est bien aujourd'hui passer une soirée
vraiment se marrer en appel d'air et la
pauvreté
lui l'a gardé une image très raide et
médard immédiat mais dans le privé il
est très divertissant très amusant et et
des limitations à 6 extra divinity non
sérieusement ça je voudrais pas moi je
fais un petit j'ai entendu moi je peux
me dire qui élit à écouter faudra y je
me réveille parce que je me suis
rendormi
sacha et marisa et marina pascik lagarde
tu es un petit côté ouvre à vous écouter
on en parle encore j'arrive à la tâche a
pesé quelque chose à dire au sujet d'
albert parce que c'est vrai qu'on vous a
présenté comme ce berger ça le truc sa
future épouse on peut le dire un moment
et une couverture de paris match vous
étiez la princesse qui étaient promises
albert c'est un ami c'est un c'est
quelqu'un que j'estime beaucoup et j'ai
filmé toute la famille de monaco et
enfin on vient de dire la même chose que
quelqu'un livre c'est un garçon à
monsieur monseigneur vous de vous pensez
aussi qu'il est extrêmement
spirituellement spirituelle très
intelligent vous de vous confirmer sa
vérifie ma théorie comme quoi les
français après avoir tué luis elles ont
choisi les grimaldi diallo comme famille
de substitution
oui vous êtes vous connaissez pas de
monaco ou non mais moi je suis quelqu'un
de normal donc il ya pas de problème
avec des chaussures en cuir
c'est pas normal alors donc karl
lagerfeld
non je pas certain qu'on aime bien les
monaco karl lagarfeld êtes baron de bas
en suède ce n'est pas les titres ne vont
pas y'a pas de particules les derniers
titres en suède comme un frère c'est
autre chose cette fois les particules
d'un croyez moi l'art est ce que l'un
est ce qu est ce que c'est vrai car
comme tous les matins je veux c'est vrai
ce que tous les matins pour égaliser la
couleur et vous protéger de la pollution
fait un shampoing sec
oui c'est vrai et je les ramène en rouge
cas d'être mère mais kaka blanc c'est
parce que vous êtes des jeux qui frise
la météo ensuite moi d'avoir les cheveux
qui frisera cannes d'origine sur les
horizons qui mélange est en cours de
route que vous avez moteur donc je ne me
suis pas content et je les brosse que le
soir quand la pollution c'est parti donc
j'ai pas on a fait ça de ma vie siècle
shampoing c et puis des cuivres la voit
beaucoup pour séduire blanc comme ça
mettra du shampoing sec et le wifi le
match comme ça et je les brosse le soir
voilà il matin qu'un autre vie je me
suis je suis gris foncé au lieu de
rouler cheveux blancs cette chute est
moindre et mathieu blanc est assez
réussi là je vous fais pas dire c'est
vrai que tous les jours depuis 11 heures
de colle de votre chien on va bien votre
chemise qui était moche comme le reste
avant le col est devenu blanc aussi
voyez rappel call c'est vrai que depuis
on l'âge de 11 ans vous mettez des
costume sombre et une cravate
oui depuis l'âge de 11 ans rudy salles
mais vous pouvez l'enlever maintenant
mais finalement
celui-ci troupes avaient tué pour avoir
envie de les enlever mais j'ai envie
d'un mercato g je sais pas de quoi faire
avec mais je fais toi questions plus
sérieuses là vous dites je n'ai aucun
but je les ai tous dépassés oui j'ai pas
très ambitieux c'est fini que maintenant
vous non non je fais pour faire et je
pense que c'est la chose la plus honnête
et la plus agréable de faire des choses
parce qu'on a envie de le faire voilà
pour tous les pères et mères pour
arriver à faire souvenons-nous est un
peu quand même
visite ce qui a commencé avec moi finira
avec moi louise and cancer clcc
personnellement oui et alors il fera ce
terrible de vous aussi c'est dans la
forme que dans le fond je m'en sors pas
mal voûte et bien j'en veux faire mieux
mais enfin dans le change dans les coups
derrière jean-pierre dans le fond je
m'en sors pas mal à mon âge je pourrais
être pathétique
oui c'est vrai et bien trop tard ok
merci en tous les cas qu'un vous restez
un petit moment avec nous